من سيحكم باكستان خلال الاعوام الخمس
المقبله هذا هو السؤال الذي يدور في اذهان
ملايين من المواطنين الباكستانيين الذين
يشاركون في العمليه الانتخابيه الممتده
طيله ساعات نهار هذا اليوم الانتخابات
تبدا من هنا من احد مراكز الاقتراع وحيث
ياتي الناخبون الى مركز الاقتراع ويحاولون
تسجيل انفسهم وايضا انتخاب مرشحيهم خوض
هذه الانتخابات او لعضويه البرلمان
الفيدرالي سواء هنا في العاصمه سناباد او
البرلمانات الاقليميه في الاقاليم الاربعه
التي تتكون منها باكستان يتم هنا تسجيل
الناخبين عن طريق تثبيت بطاقات هويتهم ومن
ثم اعطائهم اوراق الاقتراع المفترض ان يتم
وضعها في مثل هذه الصناديق والتي عاده تتم
الاشاره فيها الى الشعار الانتخابي
للمترشح طبعا هذه الانتخابات تتم في ظل
منع رئيس الوزراء الاسبق عمران خان من
المشاركه في الانتخابات ومنعه من ترشيح
نفسه بسبب حكم قضائي يمنعه من مزاوله
العمل السياسي لمده خمسه اعوام العمليه
الانتخابيه كما ذكرت تتم هنا وايضا تتم
مراقبتها من من قبل عدد من المراقبين
وهؤلاء العاملون في مركز الاقتراع
والمراقبون سيتولون لاحقا فرز اصوات
الناخبين لتمهيد الاستظهار النتائج خلال
هذا اليوم عبد الرحمن مطار الجزيره اسلام